[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
an investigation is set to be launched
in the wake of cheating allegations made
by World chess champion Magnus Carlson
this was announced last Thursday and
Carlson has accused a fellow Grandmaster
Hans Neiman of cheating saying that his
Rivals quote over-the-board progress has
been unusual
so he's a 19 year old American Carlson
by most accounts is the greatest chess
player in the world one of the greatest
of all time and he backed out of a
competition but that was uh last month
uh so I said to fritzy can you give me a
chest cheating expert he said yep he's
Professor Kenneth Regan professor of
computer science and engineering at the
University of Buffalo School of
Engineering and also a chess cheating
expert Professor thanks for joining us
how do you become a chess cheating
expert
well in my case a statistical model that
I've developed since 2006 when there was
a great fracas at the world championship
with the Bulgarian accusing the Russian
of cheating by computer cable to his
bathroom
okay so wait explain that the Q he had a
computer cable no he did not there was
no such thing because my model explained
that the Bulgarian was overlooking a
simple principle if you have only one
move to stay alive chances are a good
chess player and a computer will find
the same move depends on the kinds of
position involved okay let's get to
what's happening between these two
Carlson is the greatest chess player in
the world yes he is okay High incredibly
high rated yes okay uh Hans Neiman is
the newcomer and uh aspiring teenager
who was suddenly broken into the ranks
of the elite gaining more than 200
rating points in the past two years okay
how does that happen that you gain all
of that uh in a short amount of time
well in his case you Barnstorm around
Europe and the U.S playing chess as much
as you can including online uh so he has
a learning curve similar to that of many
young players whom I've had to track
because their official ratings have been
frozen during the pandemic
um so Frederick friedl on chess base
posted a great comparison showing that
nieman's growth is really not that much
of an outlier compared to other hot
shots of whom Magnus Carlson Was Won 15
years ago
Neiman has a couple of blemishes on his
record uh with cheating before correct
yes he did confess to cheating online on
multiple occasions once when he was 12
and uh once don't know how for how long
during the early months of the pandemic
all right what's he being accused of Now
by Magnus Carlson he's being accused of
cheating over the board in their game in
Saint Louis and more recently than he
has confessed where Mark magnus's words
and of that I have no evidence how would
one cheat over the board well there have
been many ways uh I've cases have had
people have used hidden cameras they've
had computers in their shoes they've
gotten buzzes on their thighs they've
had a Magic Pen they've had an ear piece
of phonito was used once uh so yes there
have been have in many ways
okay but he's accused of having
something on his body or in his body
with vibrations helping him make moves
yes there's a fanciful accusation that
has was raised by Elon Musk of among
others but uh there's no evidence for it
at all the people who are on site check
the players with scanners they were
under observation and uh as they have
that plus my statistical reports during
the tournament showed no evidence of neg
what role did Elon Musk play in kind of
ratcheting this up or stoking the fires
with this
well he signed on to the uh to the
vibrating sex toy uh possible
explanation but of course it's just
speculation
uh how
these are Big accusations though
how do you defend yourself if you're
Hans Neiman well you you get the lawyers
in good statistical experts the West way
you should defend himself however though
is tell the truth fully and accurately
and then stick to his story his
statements have been very vague and that
has caused problems okay are you
suspicious
well uh let's put it this way I
certainly agree is cheated online in the
past one of the difficulties for chess
is whether we consider online Gene to be
in the same category as over-the-board
cheating which is the purview of the
international sus Federation and where
its ethics commission is sanctioned
several players in the past
if I ask you best way to cheat in chess
you know over the board what what would
you say
uh yeah well there are various utilities
um maybe I should duck that question
um but but having the Buffalo Bills cap
on their head would be a start
okay so where does this go this seems
like it's a really big deal that the
greatest chess player in the world
doesn't want to play chess if this guy
Hans Neiman is in the event yeah it
needs to force a reckoning about
standing for preventing cheating and
detecting cheating at tournaments
Community stands on how we treat other
players besides Niemann who have been
caught cheating online uh and also
resolution of who has the governing
Authority I represent the international
Chess Federation FedEx
uh I think Neiman said that he would
play naked
that's right uh that's I think maybe
what's what spurred the vibrating hidden
sex toy speculation uh yes so
um both gender for shahadi whom you may
have had in your poker statement uh
poker segments and Marcel Duchamp the
painter have staged naked chess games
oh all right I might pick up the sport
if that's the case yes
uh well hey professor thanks for joining
us we appreciate you joining us and uh
giving us your insights on this thank
you very much that's a professor Kenneth
Regan professor of computer science and
engineering at the University of Buffalo
School of Engineering and applied
sciences also a chess cheating expert